hi everyone sal here
i was enjoying the view outside when you
caught me uh
welcome to today's homeroom live stream
uh today we're going to have
just an ask me anything so uh if if you
already have some questions feel free to
put them into the message boards on
facebook and youtube
and we have team members who will
surface questions to me
and feel free to ask literally about
anything
but before we jump into that i will make
my standard announcements a reminder
that khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist through
philanthropic donations so if you're
in a position to do so please think
about going to khanacademy.org
donate and make a donation i also want
to give a special shout out to several
organizations that have
helped khan academy over the years but
especially through kovid
you can imagine we were already running
into deficit pre-covid and that deficit
only accelerated as our server cost went
up we wanted to accelerate a whole
series of programs and content
so special thanks to bank of america
google.org att
fastly novartis and many others for
helping us close some of that gap
during uh this a hard time for the world
but especially covet as we've tried to
support folks but we still have a gap so
anything you can do to support
us would be very very much appreciated
so with that i am eager to take
all of your questions about literally
anything
so we're waiting for some of the
questions to come in
sometimes you know i have to get more
used to just being comfortable with
silence
so maybe i should just be silent for a
little bit
while we wait for some questions
so let's see i could go to the previous
ask me anything
and find some of the questions that we
have from there let me see if i scroll
back
to the previous ama
okay so from youtube
aurora is asking hello sal i have a
question for you
do you have distractions or simply can
we manage distractions
no i have no distractions i'm always
laser focused on exactly what i need to
do no i have
i have plenty of distractions i would
say
um for me the the things that i find
myself doing when i'm procrastinating
is uh well you know i would say there's
good distractions
and maybe less good distractions the
good distractions are i like to read
uh and so i'm doing a lot of reading i'm
actually just started on victor frankl's
man's search for meaning some some
really profound quotes in here that i've
always heard about so i thought i would
read the actual book so that i would
categorize as a good distraction it's
the type of distraction that
you need so that it expands your mind
you're not just always laser focused on
school or on work and you can kind of
think more broadly
i you know i am guilty of watching a
little bit more tv
uh sometimes than than i should but even
there there's some good
distractions and and not so good
distraction so anyway uh there's that i
try to avoid things like social media
and text messages and that i'm very
utilitarian about those things i use
social media some of y'all might have
noticed primarily to just kind of get
word out
on things that are going on at khan
academy or things that folks should know
about and
i'm infamously bad at responding to text
messages from friends and family
because i find that phones pull you in
and make you
and distract you from your life so um
yeah so those are those are so but in i
would say generally speaking though
i i do pride myself on being pretty
pretty good at
not being distracted by distractions one
of the things that really helps is
meditation which i've talked about
before
which is you know oftentimes your
biggest distraction is your own mind
your we all have these little parts that
are surfacing from our subconscious
reminding us to think about that or
worry about that or worry about the
future
or regret something in the past and you
need that every now and then but every
now and then you need a break from all
of it
and you just need to be in the present
moment let your mind still
and just kind of sit in your awareness
and when you do that
i actually think it makes your your
brain better at not being distracted in
general because if you can't get
distracted by your own brain
it's going to be a lot more difficult to
be distracted by by other things
so from youtube humble hari says what is
the next revolution in education
after youtube well a humble hurry
to give youtube credit youtube has
created something of her evolution you
know the other day i had to fix
a sink in our bathroom and i was able to
go to youtube and figure out how to do
it by myself with the tools we had at
home versus you know having to hire an
expensive plumber
and obviously there's many other things
you can learn on youtube uh a lot of our
videos from khan academy are there uh
but you know one thing i always point
out is khan academy is much much more
than the youtube videos that's really
you know even when i first made them for
my cousins that was meant to just be a
supplement for the exercise and the
feedback
of doing uh problems and so the real
part of the learning process is that
ability to work at your own
time and pace and do exercises and get
immediate feedback and if you have a
teacher who can support you for them to
know where you are so when you get to
the classroom they can
dig a little bit deeper in and unstick
you so i'd like to believe that
personalization and mastery learning
which is
which are things that khan academy is
very focused on are really
hopefully helping bringing out a world
where everyone has access to their
potential
whether you know early learner or khan
academy kids or whether you're on kind
of the main
khan academy for you know that goes all
the way through early college
i think other revolutions in education
i've talked about some of them you know
i have a separate project
it is not a khan academy project it is a
separate not-for-profit
uh called schoolhouse.world to pair
students who need
help with tutoring with volunteer vetted
tutors who are willing to
run group tutoring sessions so encourage
folks to go there if they're interested
in either being a tutor
or a a student or both
but related to that we're also thinking
about ways to certify your knowledge
are there ways that let's say you go on
khan academy and you're able to
record yourself getting 90 plus on a
unit test or course challenge are there
ways to use community to validate that
and then maybe use that for things like
college admissions
you know really moving towards what you
could call a competency-based system so
that's another thing
that i'm working on a little bit outside
of khan academy right now
but i think that could be a pretty
valuable thing for the world over time
so you know these general ideas
personalization mastery learning
education not being bound by time or
space
and then ways to prove ways to get help
from a community
wherever you are and then also ways to
prove
what you know so that it can get you
opportunities like higher
you know college admissions or a job or
apprenticeship and so you know stay
tuned especially on the schoolhouse dot
world side over the next couple of weeks
you might hear something about that
around college admissions
let's see other questions so uh
from youtube susanna garcia dominguez
who i feel like i know even though
we've never met but she always asks
great questions hey sal you mentioned
that you went camping can you share a
little bit of that trip
well i wish i kind of made a slideshow
ahead of time i could have shared
that but yeah i was um my family we went
to yosemite
and you know the it's called half dome
village now used to be called uh curry
village
but we you know we book it you have to
book it like a year in advance and we
were unsure whether we should go because
of covid and whether it would be coveted
safe but
we went you know we had a little tent
cabin it was pretty
you know basic uh but it was a great
time
uh and you know knock on wood you know
it all felt pretty safe and i think it
turned out safe this was about a month
ago
uh but yeah it was i can't highly you
know i'm probably
ruining uh my own ability to go to
yosemite when it might be a little bit
more quiet but i can't highly
i can't recommend yosemite enough it's
really just one of those places where
you go
and it's both intimate because you're
surrounded by these huge
kind of cliff-like formations that were
formed by ancient glaciers
so it feels kind of intimate but the
scale of things are also just
massive so yeah we did a little bit of
everything
you know my wife and i actually when we
were engaged we went and this was 18
years ago we did we did half dome
um when we were younger and more and
and and and and maybe more foolish
because i remember i did it on brand new
hiking boots that hadn't broken in so my
feet hurt for several days
uh but this time with the kids we just
you know we didn't go all the way up to
half dome
uh we just kind of went up kind of that
four mile loop there then we went to
glacier point
uh we and then we rented bicycles and we
you know in hindsight i should have
brought bicycles
i have a bike rack but we rented them
there it's actually a very nice place
uh to bike around in and wade in the the
rivers so
yeah it's unfortunate right now i think
they just have to close it down because
of the fire south of it so yosemite the
air is
as far as i can tell very not so so good
right now
uh but yeah beautiful place so from
facebook
neya neha dayal says thanks for bringing
in this wonderful platform for kids i'm
finding it hard to have a defined
curriculum for both my kids
while homeschooling them eight and six
years old any pointers
well neha for your six-year-old well
your six-year-old's probably at the
upper end of
khan academy kids so for any student who
is kind of
just getting their basic literacy their
basic numeracy
or earlier i think khan academy kids is
great and the kind academy kids team i
hope is going to be able to move into
first grade well they already have first
grade standards so
if you're a six-year-old is working on
first grade standards i highly recommend
khan academy
kids it covers reading writing math
social emotional learning so all of the
major common core standards you need
but if your child is a little bit more
precocious getting into second or third
grade standards especially in math
i highly recommend uh you know doing 20
30 minutes a day on khan academy
if you're six year olds a little
precocious second third grade if
you know they're they're still kind of
getting over some of the motor skills of
using a keyboard or a mouse you can sit
with them
and help them through it but let them
kind of think through and struggle
through the problems their own
eight-year-old same thing get them on
you can get them on third grade or
fourth grade depending on their level
if you're not sure about their
foundations you can use our get ready
for grade level courses so that you can
understand where they are
and fill any gaps as necessary and if if
on math if they're able to put in i
would argue 30 minutes a day
engaged if you're sitting next to them
it sounds like you're homeschooling them
i have a lot of confidence that they're
going to progress a lot in mathematics
and
reading there's a lot of tools out there
khan academy has some english and
language arts reading comprehension
things
there's other tools lexia razz kids
newsela
but a lot of it is if you just find kind
of lexile
approach lexile level appropriate
reading for your children
and have them read it discuss it over
lunch
even that can be a big deal on the
writing do some journaling
having a writing project of the week
maybe a blog that you share with friends
and family on social media
i think that could be really motivating
for your kids uh one thing that i've i
really like let me see if i have the
books
here there's a um
there's a curriculum i thought i thought
i had some of the books
over here it's by edie hirsch and you
know it's
like all things in education is probably
more controversial than it should be
edie hirsch is a little bit i guess you
could call a traditionalist
uh you know a big believer that you do
need the intuition for things but you
also need a lot of content knowledge and
you know i think
he makes i think a very compelling
argument that our education system you
know traditional education system
victorian era education was all about
memorizing facts
and probably not enough about connecting
the facts and building an intuition and
and making things and having creativity
but sometimes you know some the the
pendulum might have swung too far
where the kids aren't getting enough
content knowledge and so i'm a big fan
of ed hirsch's core knowledge curriculum
you can get those books you know there's
like what every fourth grader needs to
know what every fifth grader needs to
know what every sixth grader needs to
know
and i actually think you'll enjoy
reading them because they they're they
they are a set
kind of the essentials of what you need
to know but i think you're gonna find
that there's stuff that even as an adult
you're like yeah
i should have known that in fifth grade
but i didn't uh so i'm i'm a big fan of
that as well if i were doing a
homeschooling curriculum i would do some
combination of khan academy
uh ed hirsch's core knowledge curriculum
uh and then supplement with other
enriching things that i
i find maybe some other tools so
from facebook sumith chatterjee says
what suggestions you have for youngsters
about money so this is something that i
have a strong opinion about because i
see so many folks
frankly make bad decisions around money
um i would say that the two biggest
lovers you have
you know people are you you you are led
to believe that there's all these
secrets and there are these get rich
you know get get rich quick schemes or
that
you know people got wealthy by somehow
cutting corners on their taxes or having
incredible lawyers or tax accountants
and there's these loopholes
that's not really what really allows
folks to
do okay financially what really is you
know your career is going to make a big
difference
um and and and being able to be kind of
gainfully employed
and then the next one is living below
your means if you do those two things
uh you're going to be fine financially
and you know the career one i'll
highlight because i know
folks who you know they'll get an
education but they get a little bit
um i would say precious about what they
want to do in life
and you should be you should think a lot
about what you want to do in life but
when i say precious
you know they might have gotten a degree
in something but they're like oh i'm not
going to apply for a job until it's the
perfect job and i do sometimes get
afraid that it's out of a fear of
rejection
but you know you really have to put
yourself out there and be willing to
embrace that
people are going to reject you as part
of a job search process
and then once you're in a job you know
sometimes the jobs especially at the
early phases or even at the later phases
aren't always ideal uh and you know
there's things about it that will
frustrate you there will be days that
your manager said tells you something
that you don't like there's parts of
your job that you're not going to enjoy
and if it's miserable you should you
should think about making a change
but if it's but you know those those
aspects of work
that feel a little bit difficult that
feel a little bit frustrating that
you're a little impatient
with those are the ones that are
actually really growing you
and as long as you have a manager that
for the most part is a good person but
every now and then
it might get might annoy you a little
bit that also will grow you grow you
if the you know sometimes they're
growing you in a positive way and
sometimes
you're having to sort with okay that
feedback they give me how much of that
is real how much of that is in their
head or
or whatever but these are the types of
struggles that really make you grow
but from a financial point of view if
you're not working uh you're really you
know the opportunity cost is really
really high i remember when i
uh you know was leaving college i was
blown away
by uh friends of mine that said oh well
you know i've worked so hard four years
i'm gonna take three months off and for
me
i looked at the opportunity cost of
those three months i was like
wait that that's going to be like many
many thousands of dollars
and i had a lot of debt and you know we
i didn't have a lot of money growing up
so i was like
that's not acceptable so i remember i
graduated on a saturday and then i
started work on a monday and i don't
think i've
uh allowed myself to you know i've taken
vacations but i haven't
kind of taken breaks from from from work
um
since then uh so anyway that's my two
cents you might have other viewpoints up
there
uh but i've i've always been pretty
conservative when it came to money is
that
you know be employed in some way shape
or form
if it's not the perfect job stick with
it until you find another job i've never
been a subscriber of
you know quit a job just because you
don't like it and then
try to find another job later and i'll
tell you a secret employers
you know sometimes if you have gaps in
your resume they'll say okay was that a
gap they were just taking a break or was
that you know they'll try to read into
things so it'll also help you if you
don't
the more that you can avoid uh those
those gaps are possible
and then the other thing is just really
really live below your means
um you know budget things out if you can
but i'll tell you if you really live
below your means even like getting a
detailed budget
isn't as important because you're just
going to naturally save money
and that's the money's going to be
helpful for a rainy day helpful to
save up for a house pay off your debt
and
if heaven forbid you get you know
you lose your job you get laid off you
have a emergency in your
you know then you have a cushion to rely
on
you know khan academy at some point i
did have to quit my day job to work on
khan academy full-time
but it was because i you know we had
lived below our means for many many many
years
and we had been able to save up enough
money that it was going to be a down
payment on a house
but it also allowed us to live off of
that a little bit as i tried to get khan
academy off the ground
so that living below your means can also
make you a much more resilient
entrepreneur whether you want to be a
for-profit or not-for-profit
you're kind of in your mid or later
career so
from youtube zf says hello i'm a seventh
grader that struggles on math
are there any crucial things you need to
know when solving math problems
and making the most out of math class
time well z
what i would recommend if you're a
seventh grader who struggles in math
go to khan academy i would start with
the get ready for seventh grade course
and i would take the course challenge of
the get ready for seventh grade course
and if you're struggling in seventh
grade math i suspect that's because you
have gaps from before seventh grade
and when you take that course challenge
in the get ready for seventh grade
course it's gonna sample a lot of the
prerequisite skills
for seventh grade and so the things the
units the skills that you get wrong go
back to those units
and try to get mastery in those if you
can oh you know spend
20 30 minutes a day above and beyond
your schoolwork i know it's extra work
but trust me it will pay off
if you can spend 20 30 minutes a day
maybe four or five days a week
doing that working at your own time and
pace trying to at least get familiar or
proficient ideally mastery
in everything on the get ready for
seventh grade course and then once
you're about eighty or ninety percent
mastered on that
move on to the seventh grade course and
just keep working it you know twenty
thirty minutes a day
i strongly believe that you
in a matter of months are going to
become much more confident in math and
not only
um build strong foundations eventually
catch up to your class but
i would guess that you're probably going
to get ahead of your class and the
reason why i'm so confident here is i've
seen this over and over again
my first cousin that i was tutoring
nadia she was your age when i started
tutoring her in 2004 she was 12 years
old she was a seventh grader
and she didn't think that she was good
in math and there was no khan academy at
the time
you know just me as her cousin was what
all that was
all that existed of khan academy but i
worked with her 20 minutes every day
for her to get that help um yeah that
that's the thing i would recommend
another thing you know i talked about
schoolhouse.world
uh feel free to go there we're exp
accepting kind of these a registration
process if you want
to be to participate in group tutoring
that's a project outside of khan academy
but
uh look look for that for some extra
tutoring if you're interested
so let's see nish chala from facebook
how to help kids not make silly mistakes
in subjects they understand well
so this is a good question you know i
think you know it's easy sometimes to
get overconfident i was definitely one
of those kids that somehow wanted to go
through my math test really fast and
then i would be like upset when i got a
question wrong because i made a careless
error
or i didn't read the prompt correctly
you know that's a skill
of just being having an attention to
detail uh
and so you know i i think the best way
to not make silly mistakes is to keep
to take getting practice with things and
that when you miss things because you
made a silly mistake
that's a good part where your brain says
ah brain we got to stop doing that we
got to start reading the question prompt
a little bit better
or we got to not rush the question make
sure and maybe check our work a little
bit
because it's a very very valuable skill
in life
generally obviously if one day you're
designing a bridge or you're operating
on someone
you even if you know what you're doing
if you're rushing through it or if you
didn't read
either directions properly or if you
didn't do the analysis
exactly right it could be a disaster so
uh it's an important skill but you know
that's what khan academy is there for
because you're going to get as much
practice and feedback as necessary you
know i have
i sometimes watch my own kids on khan
academy you know they know the material
on that third question they get it wrong
it's like oh that was just a careless
mistake i was just like yeah it was a
careless mistake so you have to learn to
be more careful
which which is a which isn't a which is
a skill above and beyond
the academics as well from facebook
reshma heither
asks are colleges going to be obsolete
what about ingenuity ethics and morals
taught at
legendary institutions or institutes
i don't think college is going to be
obsolete i think there i think some form
of college will always exist
um i think college is going to adapt and
i think there's going to be alternative
paths
uh you know right now the narrative is
you pretty much
have to go to college in order to have a
a decent shot at a middle class or an
upper middle class lifestyle and that is
for the most part true i think
but we're also seeing that the cost of
college is so high that people are going
and getting a lot of debt sometimes they
don't graduate
because they might have not had strong
foundations going into it
or they do graduate and they're
underemployed or they're not they're
having trouble getting a job for various
reasons you know they major in
in you know some degree and they thought
hey i can you know
it's i can become a whatever doing that
but then realizing that the job market's
maybe a little bit more difficult than
expected and so
i think all that says are there other
paths that could be
maybe it doesn't even have to be instead
of college it could be on top of college
you know you went to college you didn't
get the skills you need to get a job
there could be another path where you
can get those skills and then get an
apprenticeship get a job
hopefully those paths are a lot cheaper
than college and for some folks they
might just go straight into those paths
and say look
given the opportunity cost given the
constraints in my life it's just really
important for me to get that
that gainful employment sooner sooner
than later
i also think colleges are going to adapt
you know right now colleges
whether it's two years of community
college associates degree or four years
in a regular college you know they've
kind of just been engineered around okay
let's keep people here for four years
and then fill it up with things
some of which is useful some of which is
not i i'd like to believe that colleges
will unpack that a little bit
that things will be a little bit more
unbundled that employers won't just say
do you have a bachelor's degree they
will say
what are the skills you developed and
they might not even care as much whether
you spent four years or two years or
or got kind of the meta diploma they
care more whether you you built
the skills that you need and those don't
have to all be quote hard skills a lot
of what happens in college is the
socialization
being part of a community having peers
around that push you
and actually i think that's the part of
college that it will be the hardest to
replace
uh with you know i guess you could say
just pure technology i think technology
in conjunction with
a really good community and peers uh can
can
you know might be a really good model
for for some folks and i think some
colleges already
thinking about blending in that way so
um the fantastic from youtube when is ap
computer science a coming on khan
academy
so we do have ap principles computer
science principles
on khan academy so that already exists
uh but the you know
the the computer science and i always
forget the a
the b um on the terminology we don't
have those yet
you know i hope in the in the future
that is something that we might be able
to address
uh but unfortunately it's it's not
currently on the roadmap
so let's see other questions from
facebook bernie killingsworth how do you
fit all that knowledge in your brain
because you seem to know about just
about any
any and every topic well you know uh
bernie
um i'm glad that i was able to project
that impression
uh and what i would say is i actually
think
most people's brains are capable of i
mean the brain is this incredible
instrument that we don't understand i
mean we're really
if you really think about it your
sentientness your consciousness
you know that part that you're aware of
is sitting on top of or within however
you want to conceptualize it
this incredibly sophisticated tool
called your brain and i've over time
learned to actually not
view the my my brain and my subconscious
as me
i start to view it as my helper and so
you know even when i have a hard problem
i don't i don't hit my head against the
wall i don't get frustrated if i don't
have a solution immediately
or if i'm having trouble learning
something i just try to think about a
little bit and then i say okay i'm going
to delegate this to you brain
and then i do tend to find in
you know 48 hours it just kind of says
okay here's a memo here's the solution
have you thought about this i'm like
good job brain
you know pat on the back you know i
don't know how to treat my brain just
yet you know here's a little you know
scooby snack for you um but it works you
know i've found that sometimes
we've all had the experience where you
have trouble remembering a name or you
know who who sang that song or
or some fact instead of getting
frustrated about it now i just say you
know what brain
you know you have to figure it out go
into the deep archives
you know get it to me within the next
hour or so
and that your brain actually does tend
to do that type of thing
and we all know folks who you know you
might not view as kind of the jeopardy
the jeopardy champion or the you know
the academic person
but they know all sorts of facts about
whatever is video games or pop culture
or they memorize
uh song lyrics or whatever it is so our
brain
can store a lot a lot of information not
just information but connections and
intuition
which is really i think how the brain
processes things i think even facts
exist because of connections that it's
able to to
to draw with other with other facts or
other knowledge however it's represented
so what i would say is you know keep
giving your brain practice
and delegate to your brain a challenge
your brain
and then i think you'll see and actually
get enough sleep and i think you'll see
that your brain actually as a
as you know as your friend uh can can do
a lot of this
a lot a lot more than than you suspect
um
yeah that's that's the best i can and
you know and you would also be surprised
if you're just a curious person and
you're always just look you know reading
and
looking up and looking at geography and
and listening you know
watching documentaries you'd be
surprised how many interesting
facts uh will all of a sudden surface
from your brain
at various times and you know i've had
the extra luxury of i've been able to
being able to make a lot of content
that obviously i was exposed to for most
part in school but now i get to revisit
at a deeper level and you know
just that exercise also i think draws a
lot more connections and
and makes it a lot more um uh easy easy
to surface when i need it
so let's see maybe one one or one or two
so smart bear wants me to make more
meditation videos yeah i should do that
i should do that let's so i
consider that done smart bear i will
make more meditation videos
from youtube rahat ali says how do you
keep yourself motivated and stop
yourself from procrastinating
um so i procrastinate like everyone else
uh you know i am guilty of uh reading
articles on quora on how to escape from
bear attacks my core feed
seems to give me a lot of information on
how to escape
animal attacks and i think because i
click on them it's giving me more
information on how to skip escape from
animal
interactions or you know you know
animal battles that might not ever been
possible but
in someone's imagination quora i do tend
to click on that so those are that's
kind of one of my
maybe not so good distractions but
there's some interesting facts i learned
from there as well
um but you know the way that i avoid
procrastinating
is i try you know every day i have i
have a list of things that i need to do
and some of them are more blurry and
you know my brain might say oh i don't
want to get started because i don't know
how hard it's going to be well some of
them are a little bit easier
like making my bed or going for a run or
meditating
or um you know just getting ready and i
find that
if i if i'm pretty good at getting some
of the low-hanging fruit i make my bed i
go for my run
i do this or that then i kind of build a
momentum i start perceiving myself and
that day is like this is a good day this
is a productive day
sal don't be afraid of diving into that
you know that thing
you have to write that you weren't sure
how hard it's going to be or that one
you know you know digging into that one
domain that you need to make a video on
that you
at first you don't fully understand
where you should jump into it it's going
to be fun
and i find that most you know building
that momentum and then just keeping
moving and just forcing yourself to
start
does a goes a long way to um stopping
the procrastination
is is my best advice um
so maybe one time for one more question
um from jean wang facebook conversations
about college with my high school senior
go sour
how should i talk to my teenager about
college especially during this time
well gene you know i'm take everything i
have to say with a grain of salt my
my kids are five nine and eleven so i
haven't had that college conversation
yet
i i have talked about it with cousins
and other family friends who are the
same age as
as your um as your child
uh but you know i think there's always
the advantage when you're like the
the uncle or the cousin or the the
family friend versus when you're the
parent
uh you know i think kids tend to roll
their eyes a little bit more with
parents
but one thing that i try to remind
myself is you know when you talk to them
try not to make it about you know what
you are telling them what to do
it's more about that you really see them
as a human being and you want to
understand what's
you know where's their mind and you know
listen to them
listen to what they're thinking and i
think the more that you
and i'm not saying that you're not but
you know really understand you know how
are you thinking about things and if
they're if
if they're kind of saying hey mom is
like she's just trying to push me
because all of her friends kids went to
college or went to that college and
you know she's worried about what
they're gonna think then i think a lot
of kids especially with a rebellious
streak might check out a little bit like
mom don't worry about it don't worry
about it mom
but if it's like hey mom's actually um
kind of seeing me for myself and
realizing that i might have
you know a different path uh but you
know i think
deep down inside most kids most people
you know i
say well you know okay they see me and
maybe they do have something that's
interesting that i could learn from
because i am actually a little bit
insecure about some of these big life
changes that
that or decisions that are in front of
me and maybe mom can help me out
so that's my best advice is you know try
to keep it as socratic as possible kind
of
more on the question asking than on the
advice side not that i'm saying that
you're
you're telling your child exactly what
to do but i've i've been in experiences
where i've had
someone else a well-wisher say you need
to do this and why aren't you thinking
about that and
i think all of us are our egos tend to
kind of
fight against that uh it's like those
force fields you see in science fiction
movies that if you hit it really hard
you bounce off
but if you go in slowly the force field
doesn't know what to do so that's my
best advice uh you know really have real
conversations with them
um and then and then see and then see
what surfaces
another thing that i've been toying with
is you know making videos about your
advice
uh and just sharing it with your you
know on with your family
uh because sometimes people don't want
advice in the moment but
or they don't want to give maybe your
you the satisfaction that they're taking
your advice
but if your advice is just sitting there
and they know about it everyone has
their moments of insecurity and like
well maybe i am curious what mom has to
say about that
and then it has time to sink in and they
don't have to feel like they have to
rebel against whatever is being told so
anyway that's my pop psychology i'm
completely unqualified to give to answer
that question um so anyway
thanks everyone looks like we're all out
of time again this is always a lot of
fun but uh thanks for joining and then
tomorrow we're going to have
a christian deservo who's khan academy's
chief learning officer and we're going
to talk a bunch about
as you can imagine learning especially
learning right now and in these very
interesting and trying times so
thanks everyone for joining today's live
stream
you